kovat 19 is the short name for the
disease known as novel coronavirus
disease 2019 coronaviruses are a large
group of similar viruses some are known
to infect humans such as SARS Co V and
murders Co V the one that causes kovat
19 is called Tsarskoe v2 all corona
viruses are named for the crown like
spikes that cover their surface called
spike or s proteins inside the virus
genetic material called
RNA is made up of genes genes carry the
information to make more copies of the
virus
the virus can infect you if it enters
your mouth nose or lungs inside your
body the S protein of the virus locks to
a receptor on the surface of one of your
cells this can trigger the virus to
enter the cell in a couple of ways it
may cause the virus to fuse with the
cell surface then release its genes into
the cell or the cell may pull the virus
inside by enclosing it in a sac
once inside the virus confused to the
sac and release its genes next the genes
use a structure in your cell called a
ribosome to make new copies of the virus
the new virus has traveled to the
surface of the cell there they leave to
infect more cells in the meantime viral
s proteins left on the surface of the
infected cell can cause it to fuse with
nearby healthy cells forming a giant
cell this may be another way for the
virus to spread between cells
people may be infected with kovat 19 for
two to 14 days before symptoms appear
the three main symptoms of kovat 19 are
a fever cough and shortness of breath
other symptoms may include tiredness
body aches stuffy nose sore throat
diarrhea and vomiting
loss of appetite and loss of smell
most people have a mild illness and can
recover at home some people who have the
virus may not get sick at all or may
show no symptoms but if you have trouble
breathing or any other symptoms that are
severe call your doctor or the emergency
room they will tell you what to do for
most people who have the virus the risk
for serious illness is thought to be low
people 65 years and older may have a
higher risk for serious illness and
people of any age may be at high risk if
they have underlying conditions such as
chronic lung disease or asthma serious
heart conditions diabetes severe obesity
chronic kidney disease and liver disease
high-risk groups also include people
with a weakened immune system including
those on certain medications such as
corticosteroids people in cancer
treatment and those with HIV or AIDS
even if you aren't in a high-risk group
it's important to practice social
distancing which means keeping at least
two meters or six feet between you and
other people
this helps prevent infections and
serious illness in others as well as
yourself
for up to date information about kovat
19 and other ways to prevent its spread
visit the CDC website at cdc.gov slash
coronavirus slash 2019 - n CoV